foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
the Tony Michaels podcast real and raw
political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
orange Jesus [ __ ] Christ are you
kidding me
hell boy do I have some things to say
about orange Jesus
and Liz Cheney for that matter I got
some things I want to say about Liz
Cheney
today's Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday and
it's Texas ball Tuesday here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we're gonna have Texas
ball at the bottom of the hour how do
you folks like that I don't care what
YouTube says
I don't care what they say we're still
working I promise I'm trying to get this
uh this band overruled stop the Steal
um you know stop the count tap the steel
no we're trying to uh still appeal
they're not listening very very well but
we're working on it we're trying our our
best over here to get back on YouTube
thanks for joining us everyone who joins
us on Facebook twitch Twitter and now
from Tony Michaels dot Live support into
Independent Media there there's a little
box there at the side of the uh the
broadcast if you want to donate to
support Independent Media much
appreciated I'll tell you what though I
appreciate you guys sticking with us now
through this temporary band for those of
you who haven't heard yet yes we were
temporarily banned for seven days from
YouTube that's why if you go over to
YouTube you're like where in the actual
[ __ ] is the Tony Michaels podcast where
are these episodes uh YouTube will not
allow us to post them there yet
here's what I'm gonna do if as soon as
they lift the band early or when they
say that they're going to lift it we're
going to take every single episode that
we've recorded in the meantime and I'm
gonna post them there for you guys to go
back and catch up for those of you on
YouTube that want to get caught up on
the show
but today we have our Tuesday guest
Texas paw at the bottom of the hour
excited to talk to him about
um some developments with the
what seems to be human trafficking of
the Florida governor who came to Texas
and now a Texas sheriff is like wait a
second wait a second that seems like
crime so we're going to talk about that
today with Texas Paul
but this orange Jesus thing
have you I mean have you seen the clip
we're gonna watch it today of Liz Cheney
talking about orange Jesus she was in
the cloaca room on January 6 preparing
her remarks apparently
and they were I don't know
they were
had papers out on the table
and they were talking about how they're
gonna object
to the certification
of the vote
because as she explains there's only one
Congress Bridge it only takes one
Congress person to object they can't all
object I mean they can but it only takes
one
so they wanted to have a list you know
for their Republican Jesus and I guess
she overheard a member say
the things we do for our orange Jesus
now here's what I want to tell you about
this first off
for Liz Cheney and I know everyone out
there thinks she's some kind of [ __ ]
hero here
which you know I'm not gonna take the
shovel out of her hand while she's
bearing trumpism's grave political grave
here I'm not gonna do that
but I will caution you don't
underestimate a Cheney and here's what I
mean
is it's really rich of her now to sit in
front of a crowd of people and they
chuckle at her as she
says the things they do for the orange
Jesus this is a person who's sycophanted
who was complacent to the orange Jesus
for a long [ __ ] time it took
her 190 days a hundred listen to the
amount here and this is an important
number
190 days after the 2020 election to go
to the floor and call the big lie a big
lie
a hundred and ninety days
the only reason why Liz Cheney is doing
this which you know I don't blame her
it's politically expedient for her which
fine I'm I am more than happy for Darth
Vader Jr to play those politics against
trumpism but do not act like do not act
like she's some kind of a a friend
friend us she is a friend of me at this
point at best
and for her to sit in front of a crowd
and have them chuckle at her number one
if she had any kind of [ __ ] guts if
she had any kind of [ __ ] gut she
would say who said that
she would say who said that if she's
saying it for this act of transparency
to show how weak the Republican party is
stop being weak stop being a coward and
say who said it
number one number two again
really is funny really is funny how the
person who was complacent to the orange
Jesus for not only four goddamn years
but for 190 days after the election was
complacent to the big lie and orange
Jesus's big lie because that's what
that's what orange Jesus would do is lie
about an election and still continue to
lie
so spare me spare me the Liz Cheney is a
hero [ __ ] because Liz Cheney is
doing this for one person and one person
only herself because I believe that Liz
Cheney believes in democracy but she
believes in a democracy where she can be
in power
that's that's what she believes in the
Democracy because Liz Cheney is no
liberal friend
she doesn't want to expand voting rights
she wants to take away women's bodily
autonomy
if it were not for her sister and her
personal connection to someone in the
lgbtq community I believe Liz Cheney
would not be for marriage equality
so don't get it twisted
don't get it twisted about Liz Cheney
now again
I'm not gonna take the backhoe out of
her hand while she's digging trumpism's
political grave but at the same time we
have to be vigilant we cannot we cannot
not politicize these things
this is very important because as much
as Liz Cheney is on our side now just
wait
just wait
just give her a bit of time
and she will be she will be your
political foe again
make no mistake Liz Cheney's coming back
around that's the whole point of this in
the first place you think she gave up a
congressional seat for nothing
Cheney's do nothing for nothing that's
for God damn sure now
speaking of producing nothing
did you see that the Cheeto dust mobster
begged begged even even judge shopped
for a special Master now I don't know
if he knows exactly what a special
Masters my belief is having
um
watched what has happened over the last
few weeks
he thinks a special Master is either a
someone
um that he pays to urinate on a bed or
or it is someone who is going to fix all
his criminal legal problems
which is not what a special Master is
neither one of those things I mean that
special Master may be able to you may be
able to pay someone who becomes a
special Master to piss on a bed I'm not
saying that I mean you know how am I to
judge any special Master rather they
would urinate on a bed in Russia or not
what I'm saying is is that a special
Master is not going to save Donald Trump
from his criminal liability that is not
what the special Master position is
designed for that's not what the law is
designed for and this judge that they
picked
was the judge that Trump wanted the the
special master that Trump wanted
now if you haven't heard
he begged for a special master
to give him back his documents I believe
that's what he thought the special
master was gonna do was just go take
these documents pick them up put them in
boxes
and put him in his I don't know in his
station wagon and drive back down on
down to Mar-A-Lago and haul him in for
him
and put them back in his desk drawers
and all over the floor in his office I'm
not sure I'm not exactly sure exactly
what his thoughts were but it seems like
Trump thought that the special master
was just going to take these documents
from the FBI in the Department of
Justice
and the dni
doing their threat assessment
because he claims these are his that he
Declassified him in their his documents
now the special Master this this federal
judge in the eastern district of New
York I forget his name does it really
matter it doesn't matter his name
these are the things that will be
forgotten
the special Master decides to ask Trump
and his team a very simple question
he asked
do you have evidence that you
Declassified these things can you show
me where you Declassified these
documents he didn't ask do you actually
own them can you prove they own them he
just said because Trump's been making
this claim the team's been making this
claim that somehow all this is okay and
it's okay for him to have these
documents if they're Declassified
so the judge calls this Bluff the
special Master as it were now this is a
federal judge but
this federal judge
is acting as the special master in this
case
and the special Master this no-nonsense
federal judge
ask for evidence for proof something
anything to show
that the Cheeto dust mobster somehow
waved his Big Mac stained hands over
these boxes of documents and
Declassified them any evidence
whatsoever you notice cash Patel is
really quiet have you noticed that cash
Patel is just I can't I haven't seen him
talking anywhere
oh
oh they won't produce the evidence and
the reason why Donald Trump and his team
are concerned about producing the
evidence that he Declassified or
classified or didn't declassify whatever
the [ __ ] he did by waving his big Max
name hand over these boxes
are just using his tiny little p brain a
thought in his pee bring you know I
should declassify these so now they're
Declassified it's not how it works
number one none of that is how it works
but number two
they know they have criminal liability
with the way that the judges kind of
boxed them in here with this simple easy
question
because it's the claim that they're
making the judges forced to ask this
question folks this judge isn't like
doing the the gotcha gotcha type special
masturbating I mean Master ism
judge is not doing that
the judge is just asking the simple
question that is forced to be asked
by the special Master because of trump
and his legal team
saying it's okay no worries these are
Trump's documents because he
Declassified him which is entirely
decoupled from reality
declassifying documents or classifying
them or whatever the classification is
doesn't make them trumps
so Trump and his legal team if you want
to call it that that's a loose
definition
his legal Dean Jesus [ __ ] Christ
where'd he get these Cracker Jack
attorneys
his legal team put out a statement
yesterday it was um really tough to read
you know usually it's tough to read
legal Motions like that just because you
know they use all kinds of legal jargon
but it was um just [ __ ] stupid it
didn't make any sense because they say
well we we don't want to tell you these
answers to these questions that you may
have because we're making these claims
because it may incriminate him yeah we
know
we know
um so I don't know exactly what happens
I don't know if the special Master can
use their powers I'm not really sure
and we we just have to have this play
out or
see some legal expert here but really I
honestly we are in new new Waters here
there's not a situation where anyone's
going to be able to predict exactly what
happens here because we're just we're
waiting in brand new Waters
unfortunately really honestly if if
if dumb [ __ ] in this country didn't
elect a criminal President we wouldn't
have this situation but we're in this
situation because they wouldn't listen
to the email lady
they just wouldn't listen I mean she was
right on all points all the way up till
today correct email lady correct
but we couldn't just couldn't bring
ourselves
to take what she had to say and go you
know that makes a lot of [ __ ] sense
kind of scoffed at it and laughed at it
didn't go vote didn't engage in our
democracy and it delivered us a criminal
president
and he didn't stop climbing in his
spreads and see he continued on and on
and on and on and on now the other news
that has come out is that Eric Hershman
you guys know Eric Hershman he's the guy
with the Justice baseball bat he's the
no [ __ ] to give at the January 6 select
hearings in his testimony
Eric Hershman was a a part of the legal
counsel the White House
and apparently
Eric Hershman has had conversations with
the Chino dust mobster
about the documents that he stole
from our government when he left the
White House he stole them
and get it twisted this is the theft
and their Kirschman apparently warned
him several times hey you need to give
these [ __ ] things back there's
criminal liability here
so we'll see if Eric Hershman is part of
the grand jury
[Laughter]
investigation when they go to indict
Trump
on these charges for the presidential
records Act and the Espionage Act
and we'll see I I'm sure I'm sure Eric
Ashman with his no [ __ ] to give
attitude will certainly love to sit in
the chair and tell them the story and I
can't wait I honestly I can't wait I
hope Trump takes this all the way to
trial makes it public in federal court
oh my God who can't wait to watch Eric
Hershman tell the story on videotape and
testimony Helen live open court who
can't wait for Eric Hershman to tell the
story about how he told Trump hey dummy
you really shouldn't have these [ __ ]
documents it's probably a crime
I can't wait for that tape that is
something that is a piece of content
that I want to see
and I want to review with you here on
the Tony Michaels podcast oh
oh this is real life it this is real
life we are living in a real time it
doesn't feel that way it seems very
strange
but this is this is real
this is real
so we will see exactly what the special
Master does apparently there's supposed
to be
um either today or tomorrow there's
supposed to be more motions they have a
deadline for more motions for the
answers for the special master so we
will see exactly what the special Master
does now this special master has proven
already just in the short period of time
of being the special master
that he has more brains
in his pinky than judge Cannon does in
her entire existence
um just going this is the question see
and this is the problem here this is
really the question of rather
Trump can prove and the Trump team can
prove that he has some evidence that he
Declassified these things which really
honestly has nothing to do with this
other than the CL it's the claim they're
making
right this this idea that these
documents are classified or not has
nothing to do with anything really other
than it's the claim that Trump is making
it's the LIE he is telling
and that's probably the reason why the
judge wants to know
is because the judge wants to know if
Trump and Trump's legal team is acting
in good faith when they're filing
motions in federal court
that's what gets you
I don't know disbarred
so
we will we will see exactly what comes
out of this special master case
and more and more Trump fraud news
uh there's a been a video released on
the Washington Post website
of fake Trump electors
going into the Coffee County
uh election office breaching the secure
area
and what appears to be trying to tamper
with machines now we don't have this
full security video but the Washington
postie we've saw this story several
weeks ago
where a
fake State elector and people tied to
Sydney Powell you know the Kraken lady
released the Kraken lady you know this
lady who's also going to lose their law
license in all the states
because of her [ __ ] lies
because you can't you can't file motions
based on lies they have to have they
have to be fact-based
that's how it works so
these people tied to Sydney pal the
Kraken Lane you know the lady who said
that um Hugh Hugo Chavez remember is
that who it was I think that's who it
was he's been dead for a while but
somehow he invented the machine that
coerced a bunch of Italians to tap into
the internet the interwebs and somehow
have bamboo I don't know I have no idea
I really don't know the Q Anon stuff it
really is getting ridiculous that it's
getting dumber and dumber and dumber
um but the actual election fraud was
committed by
[Music]
um
Republicans they're the ones that were
tampering with machines they're the ones
that wanted to tamper with machines we
see that in the case of Mike Lindell and
Dina Peters in Colorado
the election official there which I'm
sure when Gabe Sanchez gets here today
in the [ __ ] list Roundup we will talk
about Mike Lindell
and Tina Peters a little more
because Michael and Dale is on a tirade
to prove that
his phone should be giving back he lost
his bid Mike Lindell lost his bid in
getting his phone back
um which shouldn't matter really
honestly then we'll talk about how the
technology works and how Mike Lindell
obviously does not understand technology
which most people do but we'll talk
about that later on in the [ __ ] list
Roundup
but in Georgia in Georgia there is a
video released today
um which is getting closer and closer to
the state elector scheme and I believe
that this is going to be the the thrust
of some of this
uh indictments that are going to come
out of the state of Georgia but also
also what DC is interested in there's a
grand jury convened in D.C to look into
this fake State elector scheme
um to defraud our government to defraud
our election
and they took Scott Perry's phone
Congressman Scott Perry he apparently
had uh
State electors in his back pocket the
fake State electors in his bank he was
ready to do the old Switcheroo that way
Mike Prince could crown Trump president
orange Jesus king I don't know
you you insert weird storyline here we
just can't you just can't make this [ __ ]
up I mean Jesus Christ over the weekend
the Q and honors were given Nazi salutes
to their orange Jesus
while he was saying some weird prayer
with the Q Anon song really [ __ ]
weird stuff we are in we are in dire
times here folks we're just we're just
less than two months away from an
election and they're holding actual Nazi
rallies not just in in Ohio but also in
Pennsylvania with the Pennsylvania
Mussolini Doug mastriano
we are in weird times
so I'm sure that the grand jury in DC
that is convened to look and look into
January 6 but also the fake State
elector scheme I would imagine I would
imagine they're going to be very
interested
in this videotape that the Washington
Post has released if they don't already
have it
that would be my guess
we have an election coming up and it is
most important that you stay vigilant
it's the most important election of Our
democracy's Lifetime right now in this
moment in history and I know I've said
this before that as soon as this
election is over as soon as the votes
are counted certified
and those Democrats take their seats
the very next election will be the most
important election of our democracy's
lifetime because they're not going to
stop folks Lindsey Graham is on Fox news
this morning still trying to push his
National Abortion ban
still trying to tell women what the [ __ ]
they can and can't do with their bodies
and he says it's not a state's rights
issue
a couple months ago it was a state's
rights issue now it's not
when the fascists want to tell you what
to do they'll move the goal post
they move them every single [ __ ] time
and Lindsey Graham is going full all in
balls deep
on the National Abortion ban
100 percent
he wants to ban abortion Nationwide
every single state he wants to tell to
you in blue States even who elect
leaders
who are pro-women and know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about when they're
talking about a woman's body number one
Lindsey Graham who doesn't know a
[ __ ] thing about a woman's body
or women's health care for that matter
so get the [ __ ] out of the doctor's
office with the woman
Lindsay lady G
but he's on a tirade this morning about
a National Abortion bin so yes the
threat is here row row row your vote
get out there engage in your democracy
it is so important that you make sure
you're engaged
and rather that means that you are just
going to vote
you must vote that is a bare minimum you
have to mark your ballot even if you
have to crawl over broken glass and and
hot coals to get to the ballot to make
sure you Market that is the bare minimum
and you may have to check your
registration today's national
registration day check your registration
no matter what state you're in make sure
your registration is valid
get other people to check their
registration and if they're not
registered encourage them to register to
vote encourage them to know what's going
on to engage in their democracy to lean
into it
I know your pro-democracy out there and
we must we must stay vigilant through
this election
and we have to politicize every single
one of these issues
everyone's oh oh Tony that's ridiculous
you're going way too far saying
politicize everything everything
absolutely everything if you haven't
been paying attention to what some of
these human trafficking Governors are
doing
they're they're trafficking humans to
own the libs
they're using human bodies lives
families brave people who trekked across
countries and uh
thousands of miles to come
and to be a part of the American dream
these are our future leaders of our
country folks where do you think all of
our leaders came from in the past
they're migrants during immigrants they
come here with their families with
nothing
and that's what America does
we don't turn our backs on you
we don't want to send you back where you
came from
we welcome you we want you to be part of
our country
part of our diverse culture part of our
economy
we want you to be in our military we
want you to be in our government we want
you to own grocery stores and gas
stations and businesses and work a good
decent paying job
we want you to be part of this country
and these Governors these sick Governors
just are trafficking these human beings
and you know this Optics of this is
getting worse and worse and worse and
we're going to talk about
rather there's going to be criminal
charges are not filed on some of these
Governors or not it seems like some of
them may have broke the law and there's
a sheriff in Texas
that is open in investigation speaking
of Texas we're going to have Texas Paul
our favor we're going to talk to him
about this on the other side of the
break everyone stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back with Texas
Paul right after this break
foreign we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
Tuesday
you know what that means
Texas Paul
he's got some news for us which is weird
he's got newsworths about the Florida
governor in Texas very strange very
weird timeline you can't make this [ __ ]
up Texas ball how are you today really
appreciate you coming back to the show
on a Tuesday oh look at there I got the
there we go hey Texas boy how are you
happier than a three pecker toad at Miss
Piggy's Bachelor bachelorette party I'm
telling you I am wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait I want to break this down
this this is a great phrase you're
you're happier than a three-peckered
what
toad oh okay okay so so you're referring
to Kermit I I would take oh man I'm
telling you brother I am telling you
oh Ron DeSantis just picked the absolute
wrong town
to pull this [ __ ] in yeah
well well you know uh so so get us up
this be Oh I wanna I wanna welcome back
Gabe this is Gabe's first appearance for
quite some time uh Texas Paul he was he
was it I don't know if he was working on
one of these deep State George Soros
bunkers again or what but he he's been
traveling and things I was I was a bit
busy and of course while I'm gone Tony
breaks the YouTube streaming broke the
internet yeah it happens it happens I
[ __ ] it all up I just [ __ ] it all up
actually I heard that wasn't your fault
I heard that they uh that you did a
video where you were talking about
people spreading misinformation and then
YouTube blamed you for the
misinformation so here's the thing so
back last uh year when the uh when the
school board stuff was heating up and
these uh these q and honors these cult
members were going to the school board
meetings and they were yelling and
screaming saying all kinds of weird [ __ ]
into a microphone I would get on my
stream and I I would mock them and I
would play the videos just like we do
every day and I would talk about how
they're full of [ __ ]
um but they took it as I was spreading
the misinformation and supposed to try
to
acts the misinformation so because I
believe in you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant
um so that's kind of my theory here is
Don't Look Away you got to know what
these people are saying well sometimes
satire and sarcasm and jokes are hard
for an algorithm to decipher to
understand yeah that might be am I or a
troll or a troll that would go in Mass
report things I'm not sure I don't know
exactly what happened that's the video
that they took down
um and I think it was like a I don't
know eight or nine minute video it's
just a clip that I pulled off a twitch
stream that I used to do because that's
the thing is this show used to be uh
once a week and I would do a twitch
stream once a day and then everyone
wanted more and more
um content so that's where we went to
two hours a day but so yes we are still
have a little bit
um a little bit
of challenges with the tubes of you so
here we are on Twitch
um we have a new website tonymichaels
dot live you can watch there live you
can also donate there
um to support Independent Media and
support pro-democracy speech but Texas
Paul tell us tell us please about this
Sheriff
um who is uh inquiring about what the
it's funny because it's a Texas sheriff
inquiring about what the Florida
governor is doing in Tech it's all
strange give us the breakdown here well
Rhonda Santos just part the northern he
put it he [ __ ] up when he sent his
recruiter to San Antonio
um see I I know quite a bit about San
Antonio I love San Antonio it is a very
different town it's amazing but about 20
years ago they found out they had a
human trafficking problem
they had people bringing people in young
women in for brothels and whatnot and
people in San Antonio don't caught into
that it's a very Hispanic community and
if you don't know anything about
hispanic communities they're very tight
very family oriented very family values
there was a huge uproar about this so
there is an entire apparatus law
enforcement apparatus a well-oiled
machine
that is extremely good
at at dealing with human trafficking
so you've got that on the law
enforcement end of it and then on the
other end of it you've got Chief Salazar
Javier Salazar is
a wonderful individual you know people
talk about well we need good cops to
take care of that bad cops well Javier
Salazar is the good cop I mean
everything he's done he's got a ton of
experience he was with sapd San Antonio
Police Department for over 20 years but
fortunately his career put him out on uh
bike Patrols uh for a good portion of
his patrolling which means he you know
unlike being a regular cop or you sit in
your car you're in your bubble the only
other people you talk to or other
officers and and
you know officers get we all look at the
life through the lens that we see you
know everything we deal with shapes that
lens and
cops
I mean let's be honest we asked them to
deal with the worst or the worst so if
they just sit in their Cruisers they
don't interact with people they get a
very jaded view of the community because
every time they get a phone call if a
cop's showing up something bad is going
on
and they figured out down in San Antonio
a long time ago the cure for that is
like you always say sunlight is the cure
right well if you're if you're a bike
cop you can't sit in your Cruiser
I mean you're in the community you're
right there I mean if you go to lunch
you got to go into the local Bodega you
got to go into the local convenience
store and when you take your break
you're sitting on a park bench with
people around you you hear everything
you smell everything you're talking to
people all the time and it changes your
point of view and and and Salazar was
also part of what they they call the
safe initiative which was that community
policing get police out into the
community so that they see that it works
it benefits both ways
you know so this was the wrong guy for
for DeSantis to piss off I mean this is
really going to be bad for him you've
got uh deputy chief Nancy Sanford who
runs the organized crime division she
has been dealing with everything from
Mexican cartels to human trafficking to
every she is a boss she has
investigators in her division that are
extremely well qualified to deal with
this
and all of the [ __ ] they're putting
have you heard the talking points
they're putting out on this the right
Wingers
well are you talking about around the
sheriff or around the actual human
trafficking the actual human trafficking
and the sheriff excellent well
um start with the human trafficking and
I've heard most of that but what are
they saying about the sheriff too but
start with the human trafficking talking
points well they're actually uh calling
for the sheriff to be removed from his
job because he's investigating this
because uh their whole take on this I
was listening to uh Trey wear is this
this right wing piece I mean he's a
trump-loving son of a [ __ ] if you've
reached in that golden toilet took out a
big old turd shoved a stick on it and
handed it to Trey where he'd lick it
like a lollipop I mean he is just uh
Trump's like a cultist to me oh yeah oh
yeah and he had uh you know and Sheriff
Salazar isn't scared to talk to anybody
so he went on trade where his television
show and Trey Ware tried to paint this
as well these were people on the streets
lie number one they were in Shelters San
Antonio is a perfect place for an asylum
Seeker from the Hispanic Community to be
explain that explain that for a minute
explain that for a minute okay they're
in a community San Antonio
um Hispanics don't really fill out
census forms a lot they don't so the
number of Hispanics in San Antonio's
always wildly underrepresented I believe
at this point it is a Hispanic majority
City
so if you're an asylum Seeker from
Venezuela you're in a community that
speaks your language you're in a
community that understands your culture
so if you're just starting out you're
rebuilding your life
it's easier for you to do it in San
Antonio than it is let's say some place
like Martha's Vineyard where people
can't understand a damn word you're
saying
so
they are used to dealing with Asylum
Seekers and the immigrants the church is
there the the Charities there they bring
them in these were not people on the
streets if any commented whether at Home
Depot there well yeah that's where they
usually start when they're starting over
is they they go grab these jobs that
nobody wants and they will go out to
Home Depot and they will be hired to
work construction to work the grunt jobs
just to get just to get up just to get
back on their feet you mean to start the
American dream is that what exactly
exactly and San Antonio is a terrific
place for them to do it because I don't
know if you guys have ever been to San
Antonio
I have not I've been to I've been to
Dallas Austin uh uh never been to San
Antonio myself totally different town
totally different town
they call it San Antonio the Donata City
I mean everything the people are so nice
uh they're not I mean basically means
you're welcome maybe it means it was
nothing you say thank you to somebody
they always respond they're not you know
it's because the people there are so
[ __ ] nice man it is a wonderful City
I'm telling you if you ever get a chance
to go visit you need to go visit the
food's Incredible the culture's
Incredible and it's because of the
Hispanic influence there and that whole
attitude that they have that you know
helping each other out is no problem
but you know there's even a thing they
call San Antonio time where you know
like about midday we're all going to
take a break
of midday
today you know we're gonna bust our ass
from sun up to midday and then we're
going to take a little break you know
what I mean it's just it's really I
can't explain it to you till you feel it
it's an amazing City
and this is where you want your Asylum
Seekers to start off because the culture
is so similar
what you're saying about the culture and
stuff makes sense because
um you know so so many times migrants
come here regardless if it's across the
southern border or are from from
somewhere else around the world they
sometimes they find it hard to
assimilate and do American culture but
what you're saying is this is an easy
way for folks that come from Venezuela
or Trek across
um the entire country of Mexico to come
here
um seeking Asylum seeking refuge and and
it's an easy way for them to get into
the American culture and start their
American dream is is because that's why
they're coming here they're coming here
to be a part of our society they're not
you know regardless of what the right
wing says they are coming here to be a
part of a productive part of our society
and you see that in these um the 48 or
50 migrants that were that were taken to
Martha's Vineyard I want to pull up your
Tweeter for a second Texas ball that you
sent out you you think the sheriff and
you said I and many others are truly
grateful that you care but the sheriff's
tweet here I think is just or more
important he says I have officially
opened a criminal investigation against
the individual and individuals who lured
he used specific words here lured and
transported 48 migrants from the migrant
Resource Center in San Antonio Texas to
Martha's Vineyard if you or someone you
know has been impacted please email and
he gives the email I think this is
important a lot of people like you said
thought because they made it sound like
they they caught them you know the
governor of Florida which is really
weird to even say this the governor of
Florida caught him coming across the
border at Mexico put him on a plane and
ship them Martha's Vineyard that is not
what happened at all these people were
actually in a resource center and they
were awaiting some of their hearings for
their Asylum is that right
yeah and that's that that's the other
thing that that makes you know like I
was like I said I was listening to trade
ware this morning and the right wing
talking point on this is that these were
just helpless homeless people that were
just a mess and they took them in they
they gave them a hotel room at the La
Quinta they they gave them haircuts and
clothes and then gift gift cards for
food and this that and the other they
showed them a picture of Martha's
Vineyard and then they made all kinds of
promises that they were going to help
them with their immigration cases
and it was all [ __ ] it was all
[ __ ] they just kept him at the
LaQuinta long enough to that they could
gather gather enough people for their
stunt and then at that point they had
every intention they had no intentions
of following through with their promises
they had every intention of shipping
them to Martha's Vineyard and dropping
them off
and there was a reason they picked
Martha's Vineyard there was a reason
everybody's heard of it one but two
Martha's Vineyard closes down after
Labor Day
there are no jobs in Martha's Vineyard
after Labor Day these people they knew
they were dumping them into an island
that had was emptying out because
believe me you don't want to be on
Martha's Vineyard in the wintertime
you do not I mean that that is one hell
of a harsh winter you're talking about
an island out in the bay that is just it
gets blasted right so nobody knows most
people don't know about Martha's
Vineyard because most people don't have
the Bucks to go to Martha's Vineyard
they just have heard it's a nice place
the other thing is nobody knows about
the Border if you don't live on the
border you don't know about it you know
I hunt down in South Texas I spend a lot
of time Laura and I you know go to
Mexico quite a bit I know the Border I
know it's just people it's just people
that little invisible line you've got
there on the map means jack [ __ ] it
really does there are people I mean
there's no break in the people
on the you know on in the in the
topography okay your magic line means
[ __ ] right it really does and the people
that live on the border don't hate
Mexicans okay they don't they don't hate
Hispanic immigrants from Guatemala they
don't but they live on the border they
live with these they know they're good
decent people they do you get a couple
rich
Northern ranchers that go down and they
buy these ranches and they [ __ ] because
their finches get cut because the people
that walk the desert which is just a
small handful of people migrations
mainly done through airplanes
I mean it really is they fly into a city
and just don't leave they declare Asylum
you know if you've got 800 bucks to pay
a mule to walk you across the desert
you've got money to buy a plane ticket
and fly you know what I'm saying it's
it's this type of immigration they paint
about all these people in the desert is
really just a small fraction it really I
think that I think the thing for me
personally that pisses me off the most
is like I come like I've got family in
Mexico you know family and friends and
you know kind of to reiterate what you
said about the people that come into San
Antonio
these are people that are very loving
and very caring like you know my
Abuelita in Mexico she's always like
like any grandmother right it's always
like you eat more eat more like bring
friends bring family come over like
we'll do
we'll do whatever you want you know in
terms of like spending time or as much
time as we can together to actually
enjoy our experience
and that type of culture is ingrained
within within Hispanic areas and to see
people take advantage of that to see
people like Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott
take advantage of good humans
good-natured people
and promised them with brochures to say
oh if you go to this area in Martha's
Vineyard we will give you these
relocation Services we'll give you a
stipend we'll give you housing we'll
give you this and then bait and switch
drop you off and then say good [ __ ]
luck it hurts me
to my core
because I know the type of people that
are being
tricked into that
hoping for a better opportunity
that we promise everyone which is the
American dream right you know my dad is
someone who who came into this country
when he was younger in his 20s
and made a light for himself and I'm
incredibly grateful for that
and to take advantage of those people
who are seeking Asylum and seeking a
better life
it really does hurt me especially when
these people like Rhonda Sanderson and
Greg Abbott are using people as pawns
just objects to own the libs and and
make fun of the left wing people who
want to take care of people and actually
care and actually hold Christian values
which is shelter them care for them feed
them you know all of these things that
Republicans should do
you know and they and they claim to be a
Christian but don't do right and then
you've got people you know in addition
to that you've got people like Christina
Pusha that [ __ ] vile person is
another one who was falsely promising
these people by giving them brochures
she's the director of uh
I just got a tip with her this morning
but she's she's like the right-hand
person to Ron DeSantis and she and
they're both out there you know they're
they're taking claim and pounding their
chest and saying yeah we did that and
we're gonna do more of that I mean I'm
watching people right now that are
tracking flights between Texas to
Florida up to Martha's Vineyard or
Delaware right now which is the next
destination that they're trying to push
people which is on the front lawn of of
Joe Biden's home right these people
don't care about human life they aren't
Christians they don't care about what
actually people like how people are what
their well-being is they just want to
own the libs they want to make a
political point and they don't care
about the collateral damage that is
human life that lays in its waste
amen amen and I tell you Gabe and I try
to stress these this to people because I
grew up in his in a Hispanic community
and let me tell you something if Gabe
takes me to Isabella's house and they're
having a dinner a little get-together
for the weekend which seems to happen
every weekend
you know and Gabe says hey this is my
friend Paul
you know the abuela is going to look me
over and you know maybe talk to me for a
minute but I'm going to get a smooch on
the cheek and as soon as that happens
dude I'm family I mean that's it they're
gonna I mean they every time somebody
goes to get a cerveza or have you had
enough to eat or you know I mean it's I
cannot tell you how great
the Hispanic Community is man we need
these people badly in this country right
now I mean this sense of community just
over and it's why they volunteer for the
military so much they came here they
chose here because they love this
country
and they're willing to fight and die for
it
you know so many of them end up in the
police forces because they want to
protect their communities
I mean these are good people I can't
stress it enough but then you talk about
you know the crap the right wing is
saying you know the way they talk about
them oh they were Indigent they would
say I have never met an asylum Seeker
that came over here that was indigent
these are hard-working some [ __ ] they
will work you to death you know and talk
about Christian values
um a long time ago I used to sell
Windows commercially
and I would be on job sites man and I
would be showing up delivering windows
to this job site and man they would be
in the middle of lunch they would drop
everything run over to the truck and
help me unload everything and then we
were done they like hey you had anything
to eat man we got some tacos over here
this that and the other nah I'm good you
know and if somebody showed up for work
and they were broke which happens
sometimes you know they didn't have cash
they didn't have a lunch man
everybody opens up the lunch box amen
here have have a sandwich man here throw
back somebody throw them a bag of chips
you know what I mean they just it's just
it's Community human Community it's
Christianity it's real Christianity
right and these are the people that
DeSantis is [ __ ] on
when we need so many more people like
this in our country right now you know
it's just it's just killing me and
that's why I love Javier Salazar because
he is not one of those cops that grew up
in the bubble of policing and and you
know cops really do after a while they
get jaded you know you you deal with
assaults you deal with domestic violence
you deal with thievery you deal with
this all the time every day every day
you get jaded
Javier Salazar figured that out a long
time ago that you've got to get cops out
into the community so that they can be
refreshed
and they can see people as good people
again
and this is the kind of guy DeSantis
[ __ ] with
I mean he really doesn't realize he
pissed off Javier's Salazar at his core
and he will not let this go I guarantee
you I guarantee you he [ __ ] up so bad
he really did when he chose San Antonio
he [ __ ] up in the worst way
yeah it's and and the other thing too is
like you know even at Trump's speech in
Ohio right that that Nazi rally that was
there uh
you know he's put you know they continue
to push this Invasion rhetoric right
they're invading they're coming in the
only people that are coming in from
these countries are rapists murderers
and drug dealers right I completed
hundreds of miles and it was almost
three weeks finished all of these are
lies you know they're gonna make up
stories they're gonna pull uh random you
know one-off stories that yes are very
bad but then apply them blanket
over just generalization to the whole
group of people that are coming into
this country for that are either seeking
Asylum seeking a better life the
American dream what have you and say
everyone that comes across this border
illegally
is a terrible person
and and it is one of those things that
again hurts me to hear I mean we heard
it all the way back in 2015 when he made
his campaign announcement when he was
running for president which was
immediately announcing all of these
people just labeling them as terrible
people they're not sending their best
people
that's
that is 100 false 100 to say that Mexico
was just
openly sending bad people across the
border and that's what they're doing
they're doing that on purpose bull
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so this is the same type of stuff
they're they're continuing and not to
mention that that type of rhetoric this
oh we're going to send these people to
this area because you know we're going
to prove the Liberals wrong we're going
to own the libs or whatever it might be
to show that you know they got to fix
their border well here's the thing
Trump's wall is literally falling apart
Steve Bannon privatized wall that Trump
gave his Blessing to and tried to Lobby
the uh Marine Corps
um two or the uh uh the I'm blanking on
the name right now but uh Lobby them
1.28 billion dollars to get them money
the privatized company the same company
that Steve Bannon got caught for
defrauding for right they're all in
together either to scam people to Griff
people all in this idea that they're
trying to protect America
because anyone who isn't American is bad
AKA Republicans believing if you ain't
white you ain't right
and that type of stuff is going to be
the downfall of our country but you know
as we enter into these midterm elections
we are pushing beyond that to actually
have representation and actually have
voices that will push
a true American Dream a true Christian
kind of it's not even just being
Christian it's just being a [ __ ]
human right being a decent human caring
for other people and having empathy and
decency that's a that's a really low bar
at this point right but uh here's
Sheriff's Salazar
um actually reaching that bar which is
not hard to do
um like like um Texas Paul was saying
this guy seems to be a community type
Sheriff
um but listen here's the statement we
read his tweet but let's listen to his
statement here uh see if I get the
volume right let's listen to a statement
we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected uh activities involving the 48
migrants from Venezuela that as we
understand it at this point the facts of
the case at this point are that on
Wednesday September 14th uh here in
Bexar County in the city of San Antonio
uh our understanding is that a
Venezuelan migrant was paid of what we
would call a bird dog fee to recruit
approximately 50 migrants from the area
around a migrant Resource Center on San
Pedro here in San Antonio
uh as we understand it 48 migrants were
lured I will use the word Lord under
false pretenses uh on into into staying
at a hotel for a couple of days uh they
were taken by airplane at a certain
point they were shuttled to an airplane
uh where they were flown to Florida and
then eventually flown to Martha's
Vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have that
they were promised work they were
promised the solution to several of
their problems they were taken to
Martha's Vineyard from what for what we
can gather uh for nothing for a little
more than a photo op video op
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded in Martha's Vineyard um
what infuriates me the most about this
case is that here we have 48 people that
are already on on hard times right they
are here legally in our country at that
point they have every right to be where
they are and I believe that they were
preyed upon somebody came from out of
state preyed upon these people
um lured them with Promises of a better
life which is what they were absolutely
looking for and with the knowledge that
they were going to cling to whatever
hope they could they could be offered
for a better life
um to just be uh exploited and uh
Hoodwinked into making this trip to
Florida and then onward to Martha's
Vineyard for what I believe to be
nothing more than political posturing uh
to make a point well look we all know
that during a political campaign things
can get nasty things can get out of hand
so there you have it uh the sheriff of
um
um San Antonio they're talking about the
48 uh migrants
um now
uh Texas Paul he's laying out the facts
there that have been in the news here
lately but this isn't stopping Greg
Abbott and this isn't stopping
um uh drawn DeSantis from doing more
human trafficking
[Music]
sounds like
sounds like you got a visitor over there
I don't think Texas fall can hear us I
can't hear you I can hear Gabe Gabe
translate I believe I believe what we're
hearing is a cat that is in the office
space and in Texas Paul is communicating
they're talking
they're you know
I'm telling the cat to stay the hell off
the camera and the cat's telling me [ __ ]
you serving I do what I want
sorry
can you hear me now Texas ball yeah you
know what it's really interesting
because Gabe has not skipped a beat I
mean Gabe is 100
Tony for some reason every 30 seconds
you're locking up on me yeah I don't I
don't know what's going on I think the I
can the audience hear me out there I
think the audience can hear me out there
but I can see and hear both of you
perfectly fine I have no issues I think
I think the uh Texas Paul your feedback
Gabe you just uh Tony you just froze on
me I don't know
well take over Gabe
uh what do you do you have a clip for us
no no I would I was gonna get Texas
Paul's opinion on um on where do we go
from here because they keep trafficking
they keep traffic yeah well you know
first of all the where we go is the
education of people Gabe hit it right on
the head when he said that they this
this rhetoric around immigrants has got
to stop and the way we do it is exactly
what we're doing here we talk about it
let's talk about that handful that they
use as an example the uh drug
trafficking well I got an idea you want
to stop the drug trafficking draft
trafficking stop using [ __ ] drugs
because they're not bringing up up here
for consumption they're bringing them up
here because Americans are buying them
you know it's a lucrative business
because people here are buying them that
that's a good way to stop the drug
trafficking you know stop using [ __ ]
drugs
but anyways the point is
we we combat it in a couple different
ways one we need to make an example out
of DeSantis and Abbott we do this is
unacceptable two we need to start
talking about the the Hispanic community
in general with some [ __ ] respect
let me tell you these people come over
here and and that let me address that
Mexico's not sending their best [ __ ]
you know who's coming over here from
Mexico
the strongest
they're the ones that are saying there's
more money to be made in the United
States than here in Mexico I've got my
[ __ ] wired straight I'm going to the U.S
and I'm going to earn earn some money
that's not your weaklings people your
weaklings don't make it here these are
strong hard-working people that are
coming over here and we're taking
advantage of what they have to offer
believe me oh uh Porter from Porter
homes uh you know loves to talk [ __ ]
about immigrants but you know what you
know who's framing his houses
Mexicans you know who's putting roofs on
his houses Mexicans I guarantee you
Venezuelans Hispanics I'm telling you
they they [ __ ] about these people then
they use them and that's where this [ __ ]
has to stop and and the reason it's an
issue is Republicans are terrified of
Hispanic votes that's it that's the
whole that's the colonel at the core of
this is that that Republicans are
terrified of Hispanic votes because the
Democratic party is the am I My
Brother's Keeper party hell yes I am
these people come in once you get these
people stabilized
they are an engine for our economy
for generations and if you don't believe
me
look at Mr Sanchez here
his dad came over here settled in raised
a family Gabe was the first car that you
remember your folks having the best car
they had
at the time yeah no but was it the best
car they ever owned no no hell no they
went up and they made their life better
didn't they they improved their home
they bought cars they were they were the
engine of the economy in the
neighborhood and City they lived in
that's how economies work and Gabe are
you going to do better than they did of
course of course you are for Generations
that immigrant that came over that was
Gabe Sanchez's father did us the favor
of bringing in work ethic
Family Values real family values real
Christian values
and if you want to just look at it pure
from from a from an economic point of
view
Generations
of economic growth
tell me for God's sake we don't need
that right now
tell me that is not exactly what we want
right now
I mean we need to rip that entire wall
down take the steel
and build bus stations and a new Statue
of Liberty
at the southern border
that's what we need to do because they
are our savior we're an aging country
our systems that we've built that made
us a modern America Social Security
Medicare everything FDR did to lift us
out of being a [ __ ] third world
country
those are all based on a pyramid my
friends more people at the bottom than
there are at the top being taken care of
and we need good young hard-working
people
and Hispanics will do it all you have to
do is treat them with respect
that's it
and be the engines of our economy that
make sure that we as old folks man [ __ ]
look at me dude I'm getting old man my
hair is turning white you know I mean
[ __ ] I need people around when I hit the
systems when I'm relying on Medicaid
when I'm relying on social security I
need these people to be here working and
contributing
let's get over this [ __ ] man it's a
handful of racist ass right-wing [ __ ]
idiots that don't know anything about
the Border they don't know anything they
the targets that they chose to send
these people to
none of these people know [ __ ] about the
Naval Observatory
they don't know that that's the that was
the vice president's residence until
they were told
right you know and this is all about and
and then you had and you know this was a
conspiracy too because you had Ted Cruz
with talking points to go on every media
show ready to go
[Music]
talking [ __ ] about oh we send
immigrants up to Martha's Vineyard and
they couldn't even handle it for a day
they shipped a mountain under a day no
[ __ ] Martha's Vineyard is not
equipped to House people it's a tourist
location it's like you sent them to to a
tourist Park you sent them down to
Fiesta Texas or you send them to to
Disney World is where you sent these
people well the other thing too is they
were trying to get them back to some of
their hearings they're trying to arrange
for transportation back to the place
where they came from to to go to some of
their hearings so that they can actually
uh legally seek Asylum because that's
the other [ __ ] thing that's being
spread around is that these are illegals
they're here seeking legal Asylum folks
they're not here illegally they're here
legally seeking Asylum speaking of
right-wing scumbags he doesn't
understand any of this [ __ ] here's the
here's the governor of Florida this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Rhonda santus this
Trump wannabe
um on Fox news last night trying trying
trying to explain how this all came to
be he really seems to push it off on the
he calls them the vendor listen
s they were fed
they were offered haircuts and and any
other services that they were needed
correct
yeah not only that they all signed
consent forms to go and then the vendor
that that is doing this for Florida
provided them with a packet that had a
map of Martha's Vineyard it had the
numbers for different services on
Martha's Vineyard and then it had
numbers for the overall agencies in
Massachusetts that handle things
involving immigration and refugees so it
was clearly voluntary and all the other
nonsense you're hearing is just not true
and and such [ __ ] and the reason why
is because they didn't notify the
authorities in Massachusetts that they
were coming so it's all in bad faith a
whole lot of it the whole lot of it is
on bad faith and really honestly I think
that's probably gets to the criminality
of it now rather Rhonda Santos actually
has criminal liability or just the
people he coerced to coerce these people
um we'll see what what plays out but um
this is regardless of criminality this
is [ __ ] vile and it is 100
Un-American and unchristian if you want
to know the [ __ ] truth and let's and
let's remember here seek an asylum is
legal right trafficking humans
especially after you bait and switch and
Hoodwink them is illegal right right
especially when you come out of the
state of Florida which I believe is the
same district
of Matt Gates which again if you
remember back in 2017
in 2022 Matt Gates voted against an
anti-human trafficking bill so
also what happened this weekend is the
same guy came out which surprise fries
it's like we didn't even know
he was the one seeking a pardon for his
sex trafficking probe that was being
done by the doj so
these people that you know want to say
oh we gave them services and we these
vendors and we told them where to go for
this bull [ __ ] [ __ ] the brochures are
misleading they weren't telling the
truth they told them they were going
somewhere and getting something that
they weren't eventually you know they
get dropped off with no warning to
Martha's Vineyard because of course if
if you get dropped off in an unprepared
area it looks really bad and then the
Republicans say well look this is what
they wanted why couldn't they deal with
this they didn't have the services the
housing the food this and they did deal
with it and they did and we see videos
of these people at Martha Vinnie the
locals who are like yes we will welcome
you in yes this is incredibly shitty
because we deal with these [ __ ]
all the time when they come into
vacation these Republicans who have
homes here right which is also the the
the funny part about this you know and
all these people saying like oh there's
airbnbs and they can stay there well I
don't know who owns these homes all
right so you just can't let someone just
like
drop their [ __ ] off and and live in
someone's home that they don't own
but you you look back at this and again
it's like the idea that they were giving
them everything they needed they gave
them all the tools and resources they
need to to be successful is [ __ ] it
was illegal
it is very illegal and I'm so glad that
that sheriff Salazar is looking into
this and actually open an investigation
because again like I mentioned earlier I
I've been seeing this a couple people I
know that are tracking flights between
places to give organizations a heads up
of where they're going just yesterday I
think it was like 16 hours ago there was
a video that came out of one woman who
is who is tracking flights and saying
I'm pretty sure they're going to
Delaware to drop them off on the
backyard or the front yard of Joe
Biden's home and luckily they got a
heads up and they were able to prepare
better than they were at Martha's
Vineyard right but again like
these Republicans are trying to own the
libs and foil our plans it's like well
it's it's not it is not that at all you
guys are just [ __ ] terrible
disgusting garbage human beings taking
advantage of someone who's trying to
seek a better life well I've got a
comment here from a garbage human being
a fake Gabe here in the Facebook Chat he
says he's always fake Gabe you know he's
always here
um and he's saying some vile [ __ ] today
see The Virtue signaling proclaimed
Sanctuary State status but complain when
they receive a fraction of what is
happening at the border towns here's
what I'm gonna complain they're hidden
complain right here's what I want to
tell you fake Gabe here's what I want to
tell you Massachusetts wants these
migrants California wants these migrants
New York wants these migrants these blue
States these Sanctuary States want these
migrants because they know what it means
for their economy they know what the
growth is for their economy they know
what it takes to run an economy it's
human power human decency that's why
they want these folks that's why so fake
Gabe when you talk about border towns
and all this virtue singling [ __ ]
it's 100 [ __ ] right wing talking
points that you're repeating that you're
regurgitating because you're a cultist
that's why that's why if you would pluck
your head out of your ass for more than
two goddamn seconds you would realize
that most cities most towns in Most
states and most communities in this
country want these hard-working Brave
Christian migrants in our country who
are good people who want to who want to
make America a better place for them
their families their grandchildren for
generations to come and you you my
friend you my friend need to get a
[ __ ] life
and a quick Point Gabe is absolutely
right and I will tell you point number
one Perla I'm talking to you you were
part of the the vendor there you saw
that video
old DeSantis is putting daylight between
you him and the vendor Perla you're
going under the [ __ ] bus I'll give
you a bit of advice lawyer up don't run
and go cooperate
go collaborate go cooperate with Chief
Salazar I am telling you that's the best
advice I can give you because
they have a wonderful human trafficking
unit you are not getting away you are
not you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ] for
what you did now
go help yourself go go cooperate two
they intentionally pick places I said it
before I'll say it again they
intentionally pick places didn't notify
people were going and pick places that
would not have facilities to help these
people three you are absolutely right
Tony
people want these immigrants people
desperately want these immigrants we
have a worker shortage they want them
and you don't have to worry about that
anymore because the last point is Greg
Abbott Greg and and [ __ ] DeSantis you
can't do your job you can't deal with
the situation
that's not a problem my friend because
we're both we're about to replace both
your sorry asses here you go problem is
going to go away we're going to have
Democrats we're going to have better
O'Rourke here in in Texas and Charlie
Christian Florida that both of them are
more than willing to help these people
come in get settled and move to wherever
they want in this country where they are
able to find a job and live the American
dream because a they work hard two they
are some of the lowest incidents of
crime
of any demographic in this country
period that's just a fact
three they are very family oriented four
they
immediately immediately improve a
culture's Cuisine I don't give a damn
what you say I have never been anywhere
up north yeah you cannot get good food
and these people will bring their
abuelas up there and their tias and they
will start restaurants and you will have
good decent food with spices in it man
I'm telling you well me and Gabe me and
Gabe talk tacos all the time and it is
Taco Tuesday and I actually I sent Gabe
over the weekend I I may I may have went
to Taco Bell and I sent him a picture
because Gabe does not like the crunchy
tacos from Taco Bell and I sent him a
picture of this and he he said sad sad
sad and
um you know a lot of people would be
disappointed and I told them I said
immediately when I picked up the Taco
Bell taco the crunchy taco it broke in
half so yeah
it's it crunch you know hard shell is
fine I'm not a fan of it really what
you're eating is chips
in a taco good holding that together it
was a [ __ ] to hold together it's gonna
fall apart and then you're just scooping
it up out of the paper with you know
what is essentially is a corn chip but
the other thing I want to bring up is
you bring up Perla which is a good point
and actually I mentioned a name earlier
which is Christina Pusha right which is
uh I I didn't have her title right
earlier which was the rapid response
director for Ron DeSantis now
the reason that I think that she's going
to be more important and I'm not sure if
a lot of people are talking about this
but I believe this is just a theory that
the mysterious Perla woman is actually
Christina Pusha
you think you think this Perler woman is
is is is fake
well that's made up well because yeah of
course I mean they there's no
identifying idea other than she's a a
woman with blonde hair that was
recruiting people
on behalf of Ron DeSantis we don't I
know if Perla is a real like is a real
name of someone we haven't seen them
come forward or be confirmed or a photo
but whoever it is they're in trouble
whoever it is and it very well could be
that I think though again just the
theory it is Christina Pusha who is the
uh rapid response director for Ron
DeSantis right that name sounds familiar
she's had more scandals than just this
one I think she's also and she wrapped
up in some kind of uh
um foreign agent scheme as well
um where she's wasn't registered as a
foreign agent she refused and they made
her register is that the same lady uh
that one I don't know let me see I'm
just I'm just you know again when you
get all these criminals together
um yeah I mean as soon as I type in
Christina push off f it goes for an
agent so yeah uh yes she yeah she's the
one she's the one they forced yeah they
forced her to register because she
wasn't murdered Soviet Republic oh what
what what who
the former Soviet Republic what what is
the Soviet Republic what is that what
where where does that hail from oh my
God
just typical too I mean what what does
Russia always do in this country is try
to divide those wedges push those wedges
in to keep us divided and they they pick
the stupidest assass Maga voters who
don't know anyone they live up in in in
places where the spiciest thing they
ever eat is [ __ ] meatloaf and and and
then they don't know [ __ ] about
Hispanics they don't know [ __ ] about the
Border they don't know [ __ ] about
Martha's Vineyard so they could tell
them any damn thing that they want and
they're just like yup yup mall pass the
taters
they'll eat that they'll eat the Cheeto
the Cheeto cult pie like it's going out
of style
um that's one thing I want to talk about
before we we head out Texas ball because
Tuesday's one of my favorites when
you're here so I I want to talk to you
about one other thing before we leave
because I know me and Gabe are going to
get into these issues a little more
um but we have an election coming up and
Lindsey Graham doubles down on
um on Fox news this morning he doubles
down on this National Abortion ban
um I'm not sure exactly if Lindsay's got
the memo because Fox News is even trying
to say shut the hell up shut up stop
talking about a National Abortion man
like even the Republicans I mean you
have Blake Masters the the Nazi in in
Arizona who's running for Senator
scrubbing his account he's like no I'm
pro-choice now I love I love women I
love abortions this is the thing I mean
they're totally ducktailing running but
Lindsey Graham is not he is going balls
deep on this on this National Abortion
ban what say you on how important this
election is and how row row row your
vote is really important here you just
actually teed up my final comment that I
had it was the reason this is happening
the reason they're abusing these people
right now these these people that are
here legally that are going to be
Americans our fellow Americans the
reason they're doing it is to take
you know filling the room we talk about
it all the time there's only so much
room to talk about things is to get
people to quit talking about abortion
because it's killing them like you said
they're scrubbing their own websites you
know what I was part of the National
Abortion ban project no no not me I mean
hell do you see it on my website
anywhere well it was last week you were
very proud of it last week but no I mean
exactly exactly that this is a
distraction and it's a distraction that
works for him because like I said nobody
knows anything about the subject matter
and they feel like they're owning the
libs which is what
let's be honest with you what's left of
the tattered broken [ __ ] burning
husk of a Republican party is is that's
it just owning the lips and they think
they really believe Ted Cruz's [ __ ]
talking point that we were all butt hurt
that they sent people to Martha's
Vineyard or they sent people North let
me tell you Democrats are happy they did
it the migrants are great are happy they
did it the people that receive them are
happy they did it the only people that
aren't happy they did it are the [ __ ]
racist haters that make up Maga the ones
with their one arm up in the air you
know doing you know you know doing the
old Nazi salute to [ __ ] mastriano and
and Trump and those pieces of [ __ ] they
want to you know they think they're cute
and they're not they're useless they're
[ __ ] useless they can't do a damn
thing and this is just just distraction
it is abusing people for distraction
because they're in political trouble and
and and Miss Lindsay can't get the memo
she you know he she he won't shut up
about it and I guarantee you even that
is [ __ ] because he's saying well 15
weeks 15 weeks all that is that 15-week
member they came up with is they got
with old Frank Luntz and he held a focus
group where people hold the dial in
their hand and they had evangelicals in
one room separated from Republican
moderate Republicans in another room and
they kept offering different different
dates at which they could support an
abortion ban and the median number they
came up with where they lost the least
amount of people was 15 weeks that's how
it worked that's all it is is it was a
calculation to put out there but as soon
as the midterms are over they're going
back to all the bills that they're
passing Nationwide which are going to be
no exceptions which are going to be like
the bills in Idaho Texas every Florida
everywhere around the country where
they're passing these bills it will not
be a 15-week bill it will be [ __ ] you go
die well because this building
this this bill that Lindsey Graham is
bringing forward this National Abortion
ban that 15 weeks is is is and merely a
suggestion but here's what I want to
tell everyone when you're politicizing
this because we must politicize this we
have to win in in November and when I
say we win I don't just mean the Senate
and the house I mean these Governors
races like in Florida like in Texas and
some of these others it is vitally
important that we get out in Arizona and
we we make sure that Kerry Lake who is
an election denier and she hates
Hispanics she's a racist piece of [ __ ]
ask Ethan Schmidt or her campaign uh
spokesperson listen this is super
important that we politicize the [ __ ]
out of it and it is a National Abortion
ban full stop that is what the
Republicans want to do they want to tell
you what you can and cannot do and we're
gonna watch the tape um after the break
here
um of Lindsey Graham talking about this
on Fox news but even says Texas ball in
this clip he says it's not about states
rights so they've abandoned uh three
four months ago when it was about states
rights now it's not about states rights
anymore it's about the Republican Party
telling you what the [ __ ] you're gonna
do and they're taking away your Liberty
that's what it's about and you need to
you need to amplify that through all
your messaging Texas Paul give us one
last plug
um because I know you got a lot to say
about this but I I really got to do the
[ __ ] let's round up but give us your one
last plug and give us your one last
thought on this issue well I'm I'm gonna
give away my plug my my plug is for
Colonel Michael creedon he is a
candidate down here in Texas he's a
local candidate in District 24. he is
West Point grad U.S army call uh War
college grad he was a former Exxon Mobil
executive he's fully embraced the Green
Revolution and he knows for a fact that
while we all love electric and we love
electric vehicles the batteries uh means
dirty Mining and dirty politics and
parts of the world where people are
taking advantage of like Africa Etc
um he knows that fuel cells are going to
fill the Gap and he knows no one is in
better play in in a better place to fill
the gap for to supply hydrogen for
hydrogen fuel cells which which is if
you don't know it takes hydrogen which
is a carbon pollutant and turns it into
clean pure water that's what a hydrogen
fuel cell does it was developed by NASA
he is 100 percent in on the Green
Revolution and he and he sees the
industry's place in it to fill that gap
between what we can do for electric and
what what we need to do for power
generation and who has the
infrastructure to deliver that hydrogen
he is running against Greg bonnen Greg
bonnen wrote
Texas's Draconian horrific anti-abortion
Bill he literally is the guy that wrote
the Bill the trigger bill that went into
place as soon as the Supreme Court
overturned Roe that was written by Greg
bonnen that's his opponent and and and
Michael creedon absolutely supports a
woman's right to choose he is the exact
candidate that we in the Democratic
party need to be pushing to the
Forefront these are smart people he's an
engineer well-educated terrific resume
he believes in our our values and what
we're trying to do
so please people the local races matter
as much as the national races we need if
you want to flip Texas blue and have it
stay blue you need to support people
like Michael creedon I mean donate you
need to follow them on Twitter he uh is
creating for Texas on Twitter uh Tick
Tock I believe it's at MJ creden
um
I'm telling you folks help this guy out
it will send a beautiful message if we
take out Greg bonnen the guy that wrote
the abortion bill here in Texas
well thank you Texas Paul for joining us
and everyone go follow Texas Paul and
Twitter at Paul tx890 and head over to
YouTube even though we're banned right
now we're on a suspension Texas Paul go
follow Texas Paul's Channel I'll plug
I'll plug you pull
um he has a Sunday show Sunday um
yeah he does he does apparently you got
a special announcement it's the debut of
the new version right that's right
actually my buddy and I talked about it
and the cat is out of the bag we're
going to talk about it
Tennessee Brando oh it's going to be TNT
baby Texas and Tennessee we are going to
be attacking subjects every week we're
going to do probably a live broadcast on
Wednesday that will be re-upped on
YouTube on Sunday uh to compete with the
Sunday shows but that's what we're gonna
that that's what we're doing it's me and
old Tennessee Brando are going to bring
in guests and and people to talk about
the subjects of the day and you know I
mean it's just it's going to be a good
show what a great announcement breaking
news breaking news breaking news so is
tomorrow the inaugural episode or is it
next Wednesday
uh we're gonna we're shooting very hard
to go live tomorrow all right that's
what I'm doing when I'm not talking to
you well everyone
go go over to YouTube uh in Texas Paul's
Twitter account follow them at uh Paul
tx890 if you search that in YouTube or
in Twitter you'll find him uh Texas Paul
thanks for joining us we always
appreciate Tuesday's My Favorite Day
always a pleasure the best my Tony you
run one of the best podcasts in the
country Gabe
sit down so that people can understand
it you take very complex subjects and
you put it in layman's terms better than
anybody I've ever known
you guys literally run one of the best
podcasts I have ever seen guys
I am that's why I'm always happy to be
here for you guys anytime you need me
every Tuesday I look forward to it
because I know the discussions are going
to be impactful and meaningful for
people and I I just love you guys I
appreciate you well we appreciate you
Texas Ball come back every Tuesday and
everyone stay tuned Wednesday's live TNT
and replay on Sunday pay attention go
file Texas Paul keep up with the news
well stick around we're not done yet we
got the [ __ ] list Roundup when we come
back so everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after these matches
thank you Texas ball
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show welcome
Gabe Sanchez back to the show
holy moly Gabe Sanchez is back everybody
he's back he's back he's back
I don't know what uh deep State bunker
he was in Gabe welcome back to the show
hey great to be back yeah little
reception didn't have any connection you
know but now I'm here
to talk about the [ __ ] well you know I I
[ __ ] up somehow it's okay oh boy oh
boy boom look at that it says that your
content has removed due to violation of
community guidelines can you imagine me
uh breaking Community guidelines I can't
even imagine uh you won't be able to do
things like upload post or live stream
for one week we got three days left this
is from this morning three days three
days so I'm trying to do the math in my
head I'm not sure exactly when this uh
this band this temporary band went on I
don't think so Wednesday
Thursday Friday yeah I'm not sure if
it's gonna be before or after the show I
can't figure that out I don't know when
it happened
um exactly I it took me a little bit to
know to go I'd have to go back through
our texts yeah it's very well but yeah I
appealed and then I rejected yeah yeah
well it got rejected pretty pretty
pretty fast because it apparently
happened Thursday night because I didn't
really notice it well I noticed it
Thursday night but it didn't seem like
it was going to affect our live
streaming so I waited till Friday until
I was awake and had some coffee in me to
submit the appeal but within a couple of
hours of submitting the appeal they
rejected it it was an eight minute video
again of me mocking these Q Anon nuts
like this is in the Facebook chat today
holy [ __ ] Gabe it's Lively over there we
got a bunch of these cultists over there
every day coming in yeah oh my God
they're these cultists over there
they're you know the trolls are heavy
ever since ever since they had these
Nazi rallies this weekend that the
trolls it makes super heavy little fire
in there in their soul you know they're
like we weren't giving the hail absolute
the we weren't doing a Nazi salute we we
weren't we weren't we were just putting
up a number one yeah
right where's Jesus you know right right
well that's the theme of ours today uh Q
Anon warships orange Jesus but do you
know who else you know what else uh
condones white supremacy have you seen
this clip this is this is from this
morning this is quite quite an admission
yeah this is uh this is this it's the
nail on the head this is Senator Ron
Johnson Putin's puppet
um listen to what he has to say here he
would have an annual threat hearing and
my ranking member would always be
bringing up white supremacy which you
know I condone what what what did he say
did he say you heard your first oh my
God he condones white supremacy
oh man white supremacy there's another
there's another video out here Gabe I
posted it some people had small clips of
it but I went and pulled the majority of
it from Washington Post this is the clip
of
um what appears to be a fake State
electorate I think it's this lady right
here
um she was went into the election office
in Coffee County which she is they're
not supposed to be in this secure area
um I'm assuming all these uh these green
boxes are the actual screens for the
voting machines where people vote and
then there's the machines over here in
the corner and as you watch the video
that these these these schlubs these two
men approached the the equipment
um and there's the county coffee GOP
chair
this is these people are associated with
Sydney Powell this is uh similar to the
same kind of [ __ ] that happened
um in Colorado with Tina Peters where
they were stealing badges going to
secure areas [ __ ] with machines that
they weren't supposed to Jack with
um I don't know this people like Michael
and dad are like why are they taking my
cell phone right right right right well
you know uh the funny you mentioned the
uh
um the the my pillow Nazi I got a little
clip from Steve bannon's Trader TV you
know they should have locked this yeah
this was the day no this is I think this
is yesterday oh yes you know what I'm
saying is like because I did the what
was that update right right right right
right right of course he says more [ __ ]
I mean like bro well yeah he's not gonna
shut up he's not gonna shut up but this
is him talking about how they rejected
um him trying to get his phone back but
listen to what he says about the phone
because I want to talk about this this
is very important about how none of this
is actually how it works let's listen
yeah by the way did you tell him also I
know you so well over the last year and
a half you run your entire business off
of your phone did they care about that
they didn't care about that I said they
wouldn't care about that by the way look
they're not gonna they don't give a [ __ ]
the
the Assumption of of just like earned or
or like right rightful privilege right
that people have you know
we I'll get into Trump in a moment but
for someone like uh
[ __ ] my pillow Nazi Mike Lindell here
says oh I run my business I run five
businesses [ __ ] from this cell phone
[ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] right here oh
they're like oh I'm so sorry you can't
run your businesses you probably
shouldn't have been running right five
businesses from your cell phone doesn't
seem very smart like there's no
redundancy there's no backup there's no
well but wouldn't there be though Gabe
wouldn't there be let's listen to what
else he says because I want to break
this down I got a lot of questions for a
tech guy about this about the statements
that he makes
I run five businesses off but I don't
use a laptop I don't use the computer
everything was on that phone one of the
things that were files on that phone
that you can't get through the cloud
that were passwords some of them
passwords were soy wire money from
different accounts back and forth and I
have to look those passwords up in those
files so I can't get to those Steve I
can't get anything and then I got media
out there going well I called Mike on
his phone number and he must have got
his phone back no I took the number and
transferred it from from uh by farrier
to another phone but the phone is blank
it's missing all these things we need
this phone like I said Steve I would I
would have rather almost rather they
arrested me than took my phone me too me
too Mike Lindell me too okay so let's
let's take a second here because number
one he does a lot of wire transfers
apparently that require passwords that
aren't on the cloud I mean I've been in
business for a for a long time and I've
done wire trans first before but very
rarely do I need to do big wire
transfers like daily and from different
accounts this sounds really weird in
that case but here's what I'll tell you
yeah whenever I went and got a new phone
okay because I'm an iPhone user I have
the cloud which it sounds like he's an
iPhone user I don't know if we can
confirm that or not but the videos that
I've seen him in it looks like he
appears to have an iPhone yeah now
here's the thing
iPhones for anyone out there who doesn't
have an iPhone under doesn't know maybe
you can set it to have an automatic
backup right for your phone what it does
is it actually captures the entire file
of the phone now if you have that backup
that backup is not stored on I mean you
can store it on the phone but it is
stored elsewhere that way if your phone
gets destroyed or I don't know seized by
the FBI because you're committing crime
on it you could go buy a new iPhone and
what you could do from from the moment
of the last backup which would be the
night before but probably that he got
caught in a Hardee's
um you know with his with his biscuit
down and um and they took his phone
then what he could do is he could
actually give from my understanding of
an iPhone which I do have he could just
make his new iPhone just like the old
iPhone from the night before am I wrong
in that in that regard you are not wrong
you are correct you can take a backup
whether it's a physical backup that you
can do through iTunes on your computer
or he doesn't have a computer by the way
doesn't right exactly so doesn't even
know what a computer is never met these
computers there's a lot of problems here
all right so one is he doesn't have a
computer which I have questions as to
all right so then what are you running
like you need
like even if it was a web camera or it
was a camera that you're feeding us
through you need a computer
you're not just going to run an
unfiltered feed and just go well good
luck I hope that it gets through the
other end right you need something you
need a terminal a computer to filter
that through to actually go great okay
does he think does he not know that uh
that uh that a laptop or MacBook is a
computer does he not know that I don't
think he understands he's like one of
those foldy things with the keyboard on
it yeah it's not a computer this is what
he thinks a computer really is I mean he
might think a computer is like a whole
like Mainframe like uh server rack like
one of those one of those uh photos of
like an old 1950s one where it's like
the full room it's like a big computer
that's a computer with the with the
Turning wheels and [ __ ] yeah they're
like look at we're actually running this
on tape uh so I don't know if he
understands what a computer really is
but let's say that he doesn't actually
have a computer and someone else somehow
is running this I saw someone else say
he's running this over the Jesus waves
or that's hey yeah who knows you know so
he doesn't have a computer but he's
somehow running the show and doing
interviews no problem
uh when he did the interview last week
on his Lindell report on Lindell TV with
the other Nazi guy they said uh oh do
you have your phone he pulled up an
iPhone he said it wasn't his it was his
I.T lady's phone so the I.T lady gave
him her phone weird the the clip from
2021 where he's out there in his
underwear slash shorts right he's got
two phones patio he's got a phone that
he's I got on a tripod and he's got
another phone that's got headphones
plugged in
so now you've got a guy that says he
runs five businesses on one phone very
dumb he accesses files that are saved
only on the phone that have passwords
again very dumb that's like having a
bunch of Post-it notes with your
passwords all of your computer like the
number one thing you don't do the actual
thing that you want to do is actually
have a password manager like one
password or any of the other numerous
ones that are out there if one password
wants to be a sponsor of the show just
uh contact us or whatever it is whoever
wants to be a sponsor the show well
there's there are other applications or
software that you can use to actually
securely store your passwords and then
access them for all the different wire
transfers you have to do I don't know
why he's doing this many I don't know
why he doesn't have the schedule through
his like banking kind of looks like he's
hiding something I don't know but it
would seem very weird that again that he
would admit to doing so many he needs
that he needs to perform that many
wire transfers and he needs the
passwords for said wire transfers
to do so and they're all on this phone
right and if he did do a backup like you
said do the cloud which he says he
doesn't have or do a computer which he
says he doesn't own then this would not
be a problem but now he's starting from
scratch and he's got to start all the
five businesses
again if he has an iPhone he doesn't
have to start from scratch he just
starts from the last backup which would
have the [ __ ] passwords on it it
would have the passwords on it it takes
an it takes basically an image of the
entire phone I mean I guarantee Mike
Lindell is lying I mean he's the same no
no Michael
he's the same guy that said uh even in
last week when he was given an update I
was like oh I got raided in the
drive-through of a Hardee's which again
it's not ready that's not a race it's
not the onion uh it was real life but he
goes there and he says is it though is
it real life I don't know anymore
like who know like the simulation is
broken we've seen it for the last six
years this [ __ ] is crazy but the one
thing I do want to point out is the fact
that he's talking about this he's saying
like oh I got you know like uh I've got
a I'm suing Dominion right and and
they're not revealing this information
and he's like oh when the FBI came up I
said do you want the information about
Dominion do you want this stuff to be
smart Matic whatever just the other day
yesterday I think two days of yesterday
he
uh he got by a federal judge he was
denied the motion to dismiss the
defamation lawsuit that smartmatic also
has against him so the these type of of
people these these Trump sycophants are
attempting to to dismiss
the the crimes that they've done but
then at the same time lie about how they
haven't done any crimes
while also admitting that they're doing
the crimes or have done the crimes on TV
it's a it's it's really weird and really
honestly you ever knew what was that uh
look at the uh look at the whoa on the
new website here Tony Michael Tony
Michaels dot live if you go to
um Tony Michaels dot live you just pan
down a little bit go past the uh Jon
Voight uh Trump cult syndrome hotline
here and then go to um pillow man melts
down it's the what the brand new what
was that you just click the watch now
this is on Tony Michaels dot live you
can go there and and find the link for
the brand new what was that with Gabe
Sanchez uh to find out more yeah more of
the facts surrounding the uh the seizure
there's gonna be another one I'm hoping
for tomorrow that's going to be on this
Trump rally like as if you thought the
new one the new one as if you thought
the Pennsylvania rally was deranged and
bizarre holy [ __ ] this Nazi rally they
held in Ohio
[ __ ] hey man it's crazy this guy is
losing his mind on the Newsmax this
morning
um here is uh here's him talking about
here's him teasing teasing us oh teasing
us if he's gonna run for president which
he keeps teasing us I I hope I hope he
does run for president well you know
let's see what he has to say here we're
49
.ly important midterm elections how far
away are we from learning what your
plans are over the next couple of years
well you're not far and I feel that I
know what I'm going to do you're not far
and I think a lot of people are going to
be very happy our country is going to
hell I'm going to be very happy about
what his plans are going to be over the
next over the next couple years because
Gabe I actually think I actually think
this nonsense about he's going to run
for president and all this [ __ ] and what
his plans are like his his plan is to
try to stay out of prison like that yeah
yeah what do you what do you make of
speaking of trump in prison here we are
with this special Master this morning
what do you make of this special Master
news have you have you read some of this
decision
um where the special Master says Hey I
want to know what the hell you're
talking about and they're like
um what say something new well I mean
even if I I did a little tweet yesterday
which broke down like these the past
whining sessions that he's been having
he's crying and whining over the fact
one he wants a special Master right and
the doj's like
we don't need this but okay fine we will
give it to you
then the next thing is Trump begins to
whine and cry over the fact that he
wants the doj
to pay for half of the cost of the
special master that he
already whined and cried about [ __ ] I
want this and now I think I think the
doj should split the cost here's the
thing you asked for it so you should
cover the bill and then yesterday
after the special Master goes out and
says hey look we need the evidence that
you actually Declassified this stuff to
prove that your claim is true that you
declassify this stuff and that you are
actually the owner and you're totally
legal to have it we need you to prove
with evidence not just Theory like Rudy
Giuliani
but you need to prove that you actually
did this do you have uh transcripts logs
you have recordings you have anything
and then they're like whoa whoa if we
reveal this stuff
then we we well then we we don't okay I
mean really what's going on here guys is
we don't I mean like it's it's one of
the he sounds like the way that they
came across they're like well we can't
reveal this stuff because we don't want
to give away our defense or we don't
because we don't actually have it right
the way that they're trying they're
stumbling on themselves like oh well we
I'm just it sounds like Jim Jordan
trying to explain how many times he
talked to Trump on January 6th it really
what it is because I mean their defense
is nothing and I'm sure Ben maizellis
over on the minus touch network has done
a great kind of breaking yeah he did I
watched I listened to it last night
here's what I do with Ben's videos that
he does over there because uh as he goes
so if you listen to Ben and like
1.75 or one and a half speed you get all
that news packed into like a third of
the time so you can really you can chop
through those videos that's that's what
I do that's what I do
um over there can you can you quickly
okay so pull this back up I just want to
make one note of this
since leaving the White House whenever
he does these phone calls right with the
Newsmax with Newsmax and Fox News snooze
Max all these other things he hasn't
been doing Fox News though lately it's
just new right but every time he's had a
he's had an interview right even when he
was in the white house he would have
these things too he never goes on video
he does it over the phone do you know
how many hours it would take him to get
ready to go on camera game tons Jesus
Christ remember the remember the
documentary um why do I look orange why
do I look orange
yeah no no put it back no no no it looks
nope move it just slightly uh do I still
appear to be orange this is this is a
video of hit speaking of him whining
here's him whining about a closet and a
bedroom he's never been in I'm serious I
I'm uh wondering how Melania felt about
the raid
like he would [ __ ] know yeah like
what the FI he you think this guy's shot
you think Donald Trump talks to Melania
or Milani even gives him the time of day
or you [ __ ] me the [ __ ] out of here but
listen to what he says here
well
he felt very violated I
got dresses who knows what else
and uh it wasn't he's never been alone
okay he didn't know exactly I didn't I
didn't
exactly so nice the way they put it back
uh he says I walked into mine because he
he can't go into melania's room because
frankly melania's bedroom and closet is
more secure against Trump than what it
was from Russians and spies and frankly
Kyle Rittenhouse Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert was to our most top secret
classified uh information right in his
top dress drawer he it's easier for them
to get to that top secret information in
his office there in the desk drawer and
on the floor than it was for him to
actually go into melania's bedroom
gloves he's not allowed in there there's
probably like we've said some kind of
like laser hallway you have to have you
know Biometrics to get in there there's
no way this guy's going in like secure
door person and you know you got to
swing across a a volcanic right kind of
lava pit you know there's all these
things that you have to get across the
game absolutely melania's room right
especially if you're Donald Trump right
and I'm sure they live on the opposite
ends of the compound that is Mar-A-Lago
uh because he is not he's there you
should I bet they moved back in and she
was like look guys uh nobody let him
across this line
uh Baron can come back through and forth
right yeah he has the password and he
has the ability uh my husband right not
husband well you know here's the thing
he says Milani was violated he would
probably know a lot about violating
Milani I'm just well you know that's how
it goes speaking of violations here is
here is
uh we gotta listen to this guy more this
is a great freeze frame look at that a
great freeze room yeah I did I didn't
make I just paused the video in the very
beginning here's Lindsey Graham on Fox
news this morning uh Trump can't get on
Fox News anymore but Lindsay can't can
Lindsey Graham's trying to explain his
National Abortion band the best he can
he really [ __ ] it up and digs a deeper
hole here which I'm excited about that's
why I want to show this video Let's
listen I don't want to be China I don't
want to be North Korea when it comes to
the end you know Senator if there are so
many Republicans who are pro-life but
there are also a lot of republic
applicants who believe in federalism in
states rights and on things like
deciding their own laws on abortion in
this Federal abortion ban would go
against that uh this is not a state's
rights issue this is this is not a
state's rights issue Gabe that's what he
says you know it's kind of funny these
[ __ ] these these [ __ ] Mega
Republicans it was all about states
rights uh when they made this decision
like that was the whole premise of
overturning Roe was states rights it's
the state's rights to tell women they
don't have the right to bottle the
autonomy that's basically what the
decision said
um that's what Dobbs was asking this
[ __ ] halfway you know how easy they
go from uh from it's a state's rights
issue right to you guys didn't go the
way that we thought you were gonna go
when we gave you the rights right as a
state right and now we're gonna take it
back and we're gonna make it a national
right now it's a national man well and
this is all them moving the goal post
which is what they do and if you don't
believe that they'll move the goal post
again after this election if they
especially if they get in power you
definitely know they're gonna move the
goal post so you gotta go engage in
democracy because this is a National
Abortion ban that he wants to push
everywhere and listen to how he
describes it this is a human right issue
um at 15 weeks a baby sucks its thumb at
20 weeks you're encouraged to sing to a
child because this is what I am right
now okay she's 20 weeks folks I I don't
care what California does on most things
I care here I am not going to sit on the
sidelines in Washington DC until the
pro-life Community washed in his clothes
for business I want 47 of 50 European
nations ban abortion at below 15 weeks
so no matter what California or Maryland
will do these are human beings in
development I am going to advocate for
international minimum standard what
about Oklahoma they can do it under my
bill you can go below 15 weeks but I'm
drawing a line like Europe and I'm
rejecting China California is adopting
an organ Chinese abortion policy this is
really [ __ ] stupid this is more of
this China scares [ __ ] again again if
you want to make sure you save your
Liberty I'm not just talking to women
out there about your bodily tiny I'm
talking about anyone they are going to
go further in this they are going to
push this push this and push this way
past abortion way past pregnancies way
past the human rights and states rights
issue they're going to push this into
every medical decision that anyone can
make that is what their goal is that is
what they're going to do they keep
moving the goal post and they're going
they're going to make sure they create a
fascist state where they can tell you
what you can and you cannot do I mean
this is even Lindsey Graham who has been
accused of being a homosexual in
Washington DC even even so much so
saying yes I don't want homosexuals have
rights I don't want the LGBT community
to have rights equality to marry
equality across the board no [ __ ] cam
I'm telling you they're coming after you
they're coming after your way of life
and they're gonna do it through the back
door or the front door if they can
whichever way they can and I'm telling
you this National Abortion ban is we
need to pin it on them row row row your
vote in rovember baby when you get out
the [ __ ] vote and something that he
brought up there where he wanted to make
a comparison right he wants to use other
countries like China and Europe as an
example like oh well our 15 week blah
blah blah that doesn't matter the thing
that really does matter is the fact that
there is no exception right they say oh
well we're going to have this band and
we're gonna we're gonna say you can't do
it but there's no exception so if you're
raped or if it's incest or whatever you
have to have the baby and some of these
places right it's like oh if you you
know you have an abortion then there is
monetary uh or financial kind of
responsibility that you as the woman
have to repay the family of the man who
raped you right so
when he makes his comparison of like oh
Europe and China does this and he's like
you're a big big thing you're jumping
over here is this exception right not
allowing an exception for the most
disgusting and vile acts that become
committed against a woman you're forcing
that woman to then have a child to to to
to to sit with that for nine months and
be remembered of that traumatic event
that they went through right and relive
that and then have a baby and
potentially have to look at that baby
and remember that right
you are causing a lifetime of pain a
lifetime of trauma because you as a man
decided ah you know what
I'm gonna make it a national ban right
why not why not it doesn't affect
Lindsey Graham you know who else you
know what else is against uh women's
bodily autonomy this one right here
Lee's Cheney everyone wants to make her
into a hero and you know what I'll give
her a do when she when she's digging the
grave for trumpism I'm all for that I
will not take the shovel out of her hand
while she's tossing dirt on trumpism and
here's the thing of my enemy is my
friend that's right absolutely well at
some point but let me tell you something
this video right here everyone laughs in
the room this is the the orange Jesus
this is the inspiration for today's uh
thumbnail on today's title uh Q Anon
worships orange Jesus but listen to Liz
Cheney um she's talking about January 6
before the Insurrection happens listen
in the cloak room on January 6th
before the attack happened
I was in the Republican cloak room I was
working on my remarks and because I was
supposed to speak that day and there
were sheets of paper laid out on the
desks and I asked one of the staffers in
the cloakroom what are these sheets of
paper because members were coming in and
signing them and this person said to me
well those are the objection sheets
because uh you know it's only actually
required that one House member object
but there were so many who wanted to
show they were objecting that they had
set up these sign up sheets in the cloak
room and as I was sitting there a member
came in and he signed his name on each
one of the state's sheets and then he
said under his breath the things we do
for the orange Jesus
and I thought you know
you're taking an act that is
unconstitutional
so here is Liz Cheney obviously making
fun of um orange Jesus here's a couple
things I have to say number one if she
had any kind of guts she had any kind of
gut she'd say who the [ __ ] it was that
said that [ __ ]
um number one number two she capitulated
orange Jesus all the way up till the
appoint of 190 days past the election
Gabe it took her 190 days to come to the
house floor she she was third in charge
of the minority on the Republican side
it took her 190 days after the election
to come to the floor and tell Donald
Trump he his big lie was a big lie so
spare me the [ __ ] about orange Jesus
um Liz Cheney he was your orange Jesus
before he wasn't so you know and really
honestly Liz Cheney doesn't want to
expand voting rights she definitely
doesn't want women to have the right to
their body the economy and as I said in
the front of the show if she didn't have
a personal connection with her sister as
part of the lgbtq community she probably
wouldn't be for marriage equality either
so um everyone needs to to stay vigilant
here and know who the threat is the
threat is trumpism and we can let Liz
Cheney do what she's gonna do the last
few months and try to make sure she
takes power back in her party and by
doing so getting reign of trumpism but
really honestly we got to keep our eyes
on her because she's trying to take
power and she's trying to take control
of the party that wants to take away
your right to vote and you're right to
your bodily autonomy so stay vigilant
that's all I'm trying to say and oh by
the way this orange Jesus thing oh my
God
this is great this is great stuff the
orange G I mean you know I'm not gonna
say it's not funny but no no no no like
hearing her say that it's like oh well
we knew right like even if you type in
Orange Jesus like people were writing
all about this before uh but yeah I mean
the fact that she doesn't want to name a
name dude she's already on the app the
only thing she has left is to burn this
[ __ ] down with the Jan six
hearings so she's not here to make
friends she is here to leave a lasting
impact on Democracy to say we cannot
stand for this anymore so you might as
well burn it all down name who it is say
who it is reveal who were in the [ __ ]
ominous cloak room by the way how that's
so dark and mysterious oh we were in the
cloakroom I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is that's so weird it was the cloak
room with the Cheeto dust I don't know
that's just you know [ __ ] weird it's
[ __ ] weird everyone I'm glad to have
gay back I'm glad it's Tuesday we had
Texas ball great content today thanks
for sticking with us through this
YouTube band again go to Tony Michaels
dot live you can watch us there every
single day even after we get off the
YouTube man we're gonna continue to
broadcast there you go to Twitch you go
to Facebook just go to Tony Michaels dot
live all the links are there at the top
to find us go over to the YouTube
channel make sure to subscribe Show
YouTube what we're all about because
we're back there in three days and we're
gonna continue to voice our
pro-democracy speech and if you want to
support pro-democracy speech you can do
that by going to Tony Michaels live
Tony michaels.live there's a there's a
donation box up there you can use the QR
code or you can go to support.t Tony
michaelspod.com also download every
single episode that'll help us support
us on Apple Spotify your favorite
directory leave us
a review while you're there subscribing
and follow us on Twitter you're not
going to want to miss any announcements
if we get this band lifted we will be
posting it on the Tweety tweets and the
journey Trends we're working hard I
promise we're still appealing it's not
really helping much but we're working on
it we really are truly trying to lean
into this and and get this band lifted
we're not just gonna give up
um but we do still have three days
officially left on it and if you'll do
me a favor also go over to the merch
store
store.dtonymichaels.com you can grab
your dark Brandon dark Brandon you can
grab your dark Brandon merch you can
also grab your uh Ronda Santos can go
[ __ ] himself merch
um this is a great one and so go over
get a t-shirt get a hoodie get a coffee
mug whichever suits your fancy until
tomorrow same time same place Tony
Michaels dot live don't miss it you
don't want to miss it same time same
place tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast yes in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon